The joe rogan experience.
What I was going to say is that the,
the,
when we were talking about the uh,
needing some sort of a,
a lesson in how to think
and how to operate the mind.
If the human mind,
if the human body was the just,
you know,
just the human experience.
If that was an,
an instrument that you
had to learn to use,
think about navigating the human life
with the human body and language and think
about if you came from somewhere else
and the human body wasn't in the human
experience,
wasn't just a person living a life,
but rather was a ride that
you had figured out how to,
how to master,
how to accomplish and that the human
animal with its creative abilities with
disabilities or reach out to people with,
it's a ability to build
buildings and use electricity,
all these different things.
That's a,
that's a,
that's a vehicle.
That's what that is.
Learn it,
learn how to use that vehicle.
You would have intensive
study for a low for years
of just trying to figure out how to go
about the correct way of doing this.
They would be like,
you know,
you,
you'd have to figure out what
is the best way to think,
what is the best way,
what most beneficial way to you
to approach every project as a,
as a person moving around in this
human world with this human machine,
it would be like a
super complicated thing,
but instead it's just two people.
Fucking,
some guy shoots a load in the girl,
boom.
She swells up,
plank.
A person comes out,
no one knows shit.
Sound effects by the way.
Thank you.
So the three of them are standing there.
No one knows what the fuck is going
on and they keep doing the same thing.
They keep interacting with each other.
Same thing,
the way the human,
the way the human being and the human
body interacts with the world is so
bizarre and complicated and to get it
right and correct takes so much fucking
thinking.
It's amazing.
We just let these things just
go loose out into the world,
right?
I mean,
which is why people are desperate and
lonely and four stores were continents and
machine.
There's a real machine going on with,
with society today and that
machine is the building of society,
the increasing of bandwidth,
you know,
the interconnectivity that's
provided by technology.
It's all of that and it's,
it's all of that with this exponentially
increasing momentum behind it.
And we're all caught up in that and
we're caught up in that and we have
mortgages and we have bills
and we have all these,
but we're,
we're,
we're doing is we're feeding this system,
we're feeding the system of televisions
and computers and cell phones and new
clothes and distracting.
It's just,
it's so distracting.
It's like you,
you,
you start unknowledgeable and the Greek,
so I said you go from knowledge but
you don't jump all the way to wisdom.
There's an in between place,
which is correct.
Opinion,
correct opinion from when you study,
as you're reaching for wisdom,
you start to develop as the world
crystallizes around you with the right
teaching and,
and stuff.
You start to learn what the what,
what sort of the correct way to look
at and reach and follow and the correct
opinion is,
and then you finally get to a point
where you understand and can explain why
that is the correct opinion.
That takes a long fucking time.
That's life mastery in a way,
but it's like what you're saying is it's,
it's,
we don't have a system and we
tried it with public education,
but we don't have a way or a system
to really teach people how to live the
artist.
No,
no one knows what the
fuck they're doing and we,
the people that we were raised by,
they didn't know what the
fuck they're doing either.
I mean,
my parents are very nice people.
My mother is a,
with my Stepdad,
they'd been together forever.
It's like they're very nice couple,
they're very nice people,
but they were raised by people who
didn't know shit and their parents were
raised by people who didn't know shit.
And this era that we're
living in right now.
It's like human beings are just starting
to wake up and realize that we were all
living in this weird
sort of momentous world.
His world that moves on
momentum and memento.
It doesn't make any sense at all and
we're all just waking up realizing that it
was set up by people didn't know
what the fuck they were doing.
I mean,
they knew how to build buildings.
They knew how to use electricity,
but no one knew how to teach society,
how to chill the fuck out,
relax and enjoy each other.
Not One fucking person besides like
Martin Luther King and a few people with
some dreamy speeches.
Not One person emphasizes that
in the role of government.
Not One person is pushing that like can't
we figure out a way that human beings
are just nicer to each other?
Can't we figure out a way where there's
maybe a little bit less profit but also
less pollution and less fucking
with people and less light,
less control over the human populous?
Isn't that possible?
I would say though,
you're also dealing with the residue of,
of a most of human history.
Almost all of it has
been not enough to eat.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
No,
it's no doubt.
There's been a lot of things
that led us to this point.
This is also the first point.
We have a responsibility as the human
beings that have the first access to this
sort of information to not be looked at
like a bunch of silly fucks where the
people of the future,
because that's a real problem
because if I look back,
I mean living this life right now,
just looking at all that silly nonsense
that human beings are involved with.
Like everybody,
I looked on Twitter and everybody has
these fucking equal signs on their,
uh,
their,
their Twitter Avatar to let every nut
one know that they're into marriage with
the quality.
It's a quality,
it's marriage equality.
You should be,
you should be.
That's like saying you're having
that on your Twitter Avatar.
You might as well just
say water's wet is hot,
hot.
It's cold cold.
I didn't,
of course marriage equality sense.
The fact that you even have to,
who are you talking to?
I know,
but,
but seriously,
in 2000 and fucking 13 anybody we should
find out who doesn't have that on their
avatar.
It should be that.
Let's,
how about nobody use
their face anymore and,
and,
and let's,
let's find out and do the people
who have a problem with it.
It gives a shit whether or not a couple
of lesbians want to marry each other.
You're an asshole.
You're an asshole and baby,
nobody tells you you're an asshole.
But why do you give a fuck about them?
You worrying at all about what
other people are doing sucks.
It sucks for everyone around you.
You fuck everything up.
You care that two people love each other
and they want to sign some paperwork.
Why do you give a fuck?
What do you give a fuck of cheap signed
some paperwork that the other chicks are
going to be her ass eating slave till
the end of time and she'll have to be
reincarnated as a future ass eater.
And upon turning 18 resume,
her practice,
where's is this check
is going to be immortal.
Write down on paper what
fucking differences it made.
Why do you care if you care?
You're an asshole.
You're just an ass or understood it.
I never understood that.
It's fucking dumb and desire to control
of the people and you impose your
mythology or your belief system on someone
else because really uncreative fucks
to are not thinking about how ridiculous
you're going to look in the future when
they're looking back on the past,
the way they looked at those idiots that
thought that leaches were the best way
to cure your broken leg.
That goes fucking people.
We laugh at them today and don't tell
me about scientific applications of
leeches.
You have fucks because there's none.
I can just,
you can nudge
people like,
you know,
there are medical
applications for leaches.
Like people send me that cause
I was making fun of for gang.
Green Bay can use it for stuff.
But guess what?
Medicine works better
for almost everything.